think back to the start of turn three
where we began this course what is the
theme of this course what's that big
deeply about simple things very good
okay so here's what we going to do we're
going to take the situation where she
was kind of well innocuous and
uninteresting and we're gonna try and
dig into it okay so what do we determine
so far for the bridges of königsberg the
problem is to try and cross all the
bridges just once right that's that's
the issue okay so this problem was
actually presented to that most famous
management mathematician so this was
like 300 years ago okay and Euler he
kind of has this way of getting into
everywhere in maths like he contributed
to all the different kinds of fields of
maths that we know and our view is
called the the master of us all okay
now what I thought about was that we'll
look this problem here it's very very
concrete it's a it's an actual city and
there were actual bridges but to
consider this mathematically you can
boil it down right you don't need all
this everything in this picture okay
so for example if I simplify this a
little bit and I'd like you to join me
in doing this okay like think about the
shape of this river okay the shape of
the river doesn't really matter okay
this should be resubmission of something
that we looked at under the topic beauty
and mathematics do you remember we had a
look at something else where the shape
of it didn't really matter you would
remember yeah very good is what we would
have you look at maps maps and we're
having with colouring maps and inner
topology which is related to this the
actual shapes of things didn't matter it
was their relationships okay so I'm
gonna redraw this and a Bucky to join me
I'm gonna redraw it in a simpler way
okay so I'm gonna draw it a bit like
this
my picture so I've got one in the middle
here okay so when you have a look at
this situation right there isn't much
symmetry to it is there right like you
got pairs of bridges and all that but
it's kind of lopsided but actually what
you think about the relationships of the
landmasses of the bridges it is
symmetrical let me get my own my bridge
cover you have a look you've got two
down and two up right to here and to
here right that's symmetrical you've got
one across here and then you've got
again the one up one down situation okay
so this is kind of a simplified version
of this map which helps you see the
structures that are there and you don't
get distracted by the fact that even
though this has bend in the river and
all I can't move it but even this can be
boiled down okay because for instance
see how you've got like a landmass here
and a landmass over here right or a big
landmass over here the sizes of these
land masses are related to each other it
doesn't matter does it
what matters is what's connected okay so
in fact I'm going to say this is equal
to something even simpler okay instead
of land masses if I just represent those
as points how many points are there not
breaches how many points are there that
are joined by bridges to think if you
label them what would they be called so
some of the vendors this here right this
is a landmass icns five bridges coming
off in it but it's just one leg baths
right so for example if I call that a
okay what would be another landmass that
I could name what which would like they
call be the one in the middle yeah yeah
okay
so what should I name next what what
would you like me to call see okay the
top and you can see by the way see and
all of this it's all one landmass right
and this is D down here so there are
really only four places that I need to
connect does that make sense yeah we're
going to simplify it even further if all
we had is these four themes support
places
just going to represent than my points
right so if I have a you put B over here
we had C above and D bullet so when I
joined these all you need to think about
is how many bridges connect all the
plates so for instance time your bridges
are there between a and C two very good
one too so far so good
how many British you're a daddy also two
and then you've got three bridges or
coming away from B does that make sense
one soon three okay so this is a kind of
like mathematical abstraction of this
does that make sense
so these are really all the same now
when you see this we should have put
some of labels on these things
this is called a network diagram in fact
this up the bridges of königsberg is a
problem under the topic of network
theory networking which means something
very important you see this problem you
kind of like what the point you can
cross it where you can't cross it begins
just go halfway across what region
couple halfway together or swim well I
don't know okay well when you realize
this is about networks okay these kinds
of problems are like kind of like the
backbone of happenings like the internet
work right these kinds of problems are
enormously relevant to a G's from trying
to make networks actually function okay
so we've got here four points we call
these vertices right so I would call
this one like vertex C okay if I take a
vertex B but it's okay
instead of bridges what we call these
things are edges okay so you have
vertices and you have edges now there
are two ways to go through our city our
network
okay the first way is with what we call
a simplify a sitting part is just a way
to visit every vertex and visit it once
okay so usually a simple path is quite
easy to work out for example I could go
I could start at C I go C - a - D - B
it's a simple part I visited every
vertex does that make sense
but what we're looking at is more
interesting right because this was this
idea was playing if I am whele instead
of being called a simple path these are
called Euler paths
okay so oil path is can you cross every
bridge once which is another way of
saying instead of visiting every vertex
I want to visit every edge just once
okay so what we were looking for before
is an Euler path through this diagram
through this network okay and the point
is it doesn't exist and it cut